[Musique]
e
le
[Musique]
je voulais dire
journée d'étude
j'ouvre les portes et je marche quand
elles sont ouvertes qu'on ne puisse plus
les refermer
jamais merci de m'avoir permis
le show sera capable de revenir en ville
c'est pas vivre le théâtre c'est ma vie
j'ai la plus belle façon de vivre
le mot le plus caractéristique de notre
action dans les mois et les années qui
viennent c'est le mot nous ensemble nous
les souverainistes
nous allons aller convaincre nos
compatriotes
[Musique]
ce n'est pas gai
et
ou non d'une façon générale augmenter la
qualité de l'enseignement
[Musique]
être mécène c'est bien mais les bijoux
ciel c'est vraiment quelque chose ça
c'est vraiment quelque chose à tenir
je crois que mes gènes sont des amis
préférés
[Musique]
que chacun se mette à chanter
et que chaque instant
[Musique]
tous les jours
moscou
[Musique]
il n'y a pas assez fait pour tous
du coup
[Musique]
fin juin
pas ausy quelque chose tu peux faire
c'est quand il ya des tâches jean
villanove
[Musique]
sa lecture est malade
car les gens vont voir ça dans les
archives j étais tu y as if ils vont
s'appeler disent les deux des biens
wakfs chose
[Musique]
woods le savait
il aurait dû
moi
[Musique]
desautels il faudrait sur le champ que
je me l'ont pu tu as accès bon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bon